we're joined in the studio now once
again by the health secretary sergeant
minister great to have you good morning
on the program um
let's just reflect of course plenty to
talk about in terms of your brief but
let's reflect on what we have seen
coming out of ukraine over the past 24
hours i personally have watched more
footage from ukraine than i would care
to ever admit to but this weekend seeing
children being pulled out of the rubble
kind of brought it home to me
is the british government yet to the
point where they can they can join
the ukrainian president ukrainian deputy
prime minister in describing what we're
seeing in ukraine as a as a genocide
look like everyone i'm appalled by the
the scenes coming out of ukraine right
now the despicable attacks on civilians
when i was last in your studio that was
a day we saw the picture of that the the
woman from a maternity hospital a
pregnant woman that'd be murdered uh by
the russians and now we're seeing
children being pulled out of rubble it's
in terms of um holding russia
accountable in russia and the president
putin he will absolutely be held
accountable for this
there's a there's an international
criminal court that will
work on this and they're already
compiling evidence the deputy prime
minister was in the hague last week
offering the uk's full support to hold
russia to account in the meantime we
will of course will continue to support
the ukrainians in every single way that
we can
i i do wonder though we heard from the
former prime minister gordon brown at
the weekend pointing out the problems
that there may well be with the
international criminal court process
least not least of which is there's not
a chance that we're going to be able to
extradite vladimir putin from russia to
face charges directly what do you make
of his suggestion that there is perhaps
a nuremberg style trial set up to try
and prosecute this which we can
prosecute in absentee if necessary look
i think all of that should be looked at
i think it's right that uh gordon brown
and others many people are thinking
about the the what ways and mechanisms
can the international community use to
hold russia to account i mean right here
and now i think it's really important
that we and our allies continue to
support russia in er because supporting
ukraine in in every way
with the military aid that we're
providing i think more than any other
country the humanitarian support that
we're providing as well all of this is
crucial but also making sure that russia
is held to account i i i understand that
this is not your brief i understand that
they're all cabinet ministers will want
to be careful with their language but
but i will note that you don't feel
comfortable going as far as the
as the ukrainian president and and being
literal about this stating that in your
view given what we have seen you feel
that he's committing accidents what
president zielenski thinks is very very
important to us we of course will listen
to him carefully the prime minister our
prime minister uh talks to him on a
regular basis and we will help the
ukrainians gather all the evidence they
need for successful prosecutions
whenever we can where are we at the
moment with the scheme to raise house
ukrainians coming to the united kingdom
um 3.4 million people have fled the
country at the moment and the concerns
are particularly from agencies working
in non-governmental organizations
working in this field is that we're not
being quick enough to match people up
well my understanding is with the so
there's two schemes at the moment with
the family reunification scheme i think
some nine and a half thousand visas have
been issued
with the hosting a ukrainian family
scheme i think some over 150 000 people
have registered their interest and the
process of matching those hosts with
with families from ukraine has begun
can i just ask about something that the
home secretary mentioned at the weekend
which i haven't really seen picked up
particularly widely we know that we have
had a different approach as regards
visas for ukrainians coming to this
country she said this the truth is that
a very small number of people can wreak
utter havoc and russia has a history of
covert hostile activity
are we really suggesting that we believe
that there could be russian agents
coming to this country under false
ukrainian passports and that's what the
home secretary is suggesting and she's
right too by the way to to point that
out
let's let's let's just what end would
russia be coming in in that fashion we
know the russians have done that they
did it in 2018 when i had her job
and we
we saw in our country russian agents
came here with a deadly nerve agent a
chemical weapon
and they used it in salisbury
we know it killed people and russia was
directly responsible for that they
infiltrated our country with agents with
a chemical weapon and used it and so it
is right there there are some level of
of security checks we also know that
extremists and extremist organizations
operate in that region of course the the
level of security checks has to be
proportionate uh to the the the issues
that we're dealing with the example that
you get in the same time
in the way of of letting ukrainians come
here to safety sure but the example you
gave of salisbury my understanding is
those two russians arrived on a russian
passport on a tourist visa
in what way would these these security
checks stop them coming well it wouldn't
be it wouldn't make sense to get into
detail about how our checks work uh
precisely but i think most people would
understand that we do what we can to
protect our homeland let you've been
very good so let's talk on speaking away
from your brief so let's move on to it
covered cases are clearly on the upswing
at the moment do you have an estimate of
when we might reach the peak
um i think with omicron
we have
we're past the peak now we've come down
from that level the although infections
are rising case numbers are rising and
hospitalizations have risen a bit as
well over the last two weeks they're
still way below their peak it's also
worth uh sort of keeping in mind why
we're seeing rises that was always going
to be the case when we opened up and
also we have a sub-variant let's call it
of the original omicron called ba2 which
we know on the one hand is more
infectious than the original omicron
variant but
thankfully these vaccines that we have
are just as effective against it
why is it taking so long to get to this
next stage of the rollout by my
reckoning we're about six months away
from the start of the third dose scheme
and we know of course that resistance
wins a lot quicker than you know within
six months should we perhaps have got to
this point slightly quicker or is it all
because of the jcvi no i think we're
exactly the the right places when it
comes to vaccine waning and
effectiveness it's something we monitor
almost on a daily basis i think as a
country we've probably done more
research on on that than any other
country but this is winning resistance
part of the reason why we are seeing
increased er infections increased i
think the the primary reasons are the
ones i mentioned which are increased uh
social mixing and uh also this ba2
subvariant the announcement today which
is a a spring booster dose
for those that are over 75 elderly
people living in care homes and the
immunosuppressed this will allow that
group of people which are at more
serious risk than others to top up their
protection against this virus and and
and give them that extra level of
confidence that they need is it not
somewhat counterintuitive at a point
which we're suggesting that over 75
people who are vulnerable should be able
to get a fourth dose that we're about a
fortnight away from the ending of free
covenant testing
um no i don't think the the two things
are necessarily related i mean our
primary
do you not think that if you remove free
testing fewer people will test
well obviously if there's fewer tests
around then than fuel will be used but
the the question really is do we still
need to have a universal free testing
offer which is as it sounds yes for
everyone whenever they want to test and
our determination based on the advice
that we receive is that is no longer
necessary we're in a much better stage
with kobe than we have been so far
clearly it's still there that's why we
still need to keep focusing on our
defenses but the best defense is
vaccination we've built a wall of
defense it's working in fact i think
this weekend the uk health security
agency they said in their analysis that
since december because of the booster
push that we had we've kept some 157
thousand people out of hospital so
vaccines work and that is why everyone
that's eligible please should come
forward
just just briefly should we expect a
broader rollout of a fourth dose well
the jcvi that's our group of independent
advisors they have said they are looking
at a autumn dose for over 50s but
there's no final decision at this point
in time can we just reflect just a
briefly um
going back to ukraine on the comments
that the prime minister made at the
weekend drawing a comparison in his mind
between
voting to leave the european union
and fighting against a russian invasion
of ukraine did you think it was
appropriate he seemed to suggest that
those who who didn't vote against brexit
like yourself were somehow not lovers of
freedom
well i i heard his comments and i don't
think he was suggesting that at all what
i heard from the prime minister was uh
the the basically the desire for
self-determination in in everyone no
matter what country they're in no matter
what their circumstance is strong i
don't think in any way he was connecting
the situations in ukraine and the uk and
if we want to know what the prime
minister thinks about ukraine and
responding i mean we can see for
ourselves in terms of the support that
he's provided you know rock solid
support compared to any other world
leader you don't you don't think it was
a tall crass for the prime minister to
make that comparison or to allude to a
comparison i mean the perp the brexit i
don't i don't think i don't accept that
he was comparing uk he mentioned one and
he mentioned the other in the series his
point his point was about
the importance of self-determination and
and people you know whoever they are
wherever they are they have this strong
feeling of wanting to have freedom and
determine i'm just i'm just generally
suggesting that the self-determination
you know shown by the brits who voted to
leave a political and economic union
it's not the same as the
self-determination shown by people who
are picking up guns and firing on
invaders and he wasn't saying i think
it's spurious to say that he was
connecting somehow
in that way well i i i think most normal
people listening to that wouldn't have
drawn that conclusion i think you can
see what he's talking about which is
just about the importance of
self-determination just just a final
point of course on all eyes this week on
what the chancellor does come come
wednesday and you i'm sure will not be
drawn on perhaps more money for your or
whatever else but just in terms of the
strategy currently isn't that isn't the
single biggest beneficiary of the rise
in the cost of living right now the the
treasury that any wiggle room that the
treasury has right now is down to
increase tax take at the petrol pumps
v80 and so on well look one of the
benefits of no longer being chancellor
is i don't really have to answer those
questions
sadie javits we'll leave it there thanks
for being with us thank you